Ashley tiene solo 12 años pero su
inquietud por descubrir el universo la
ha llevado lejos Pues lo que veo que me
gusta más en el sol
son las que se ven pues se ven
impresionantes se ven muy a detalle
guiada por su padre la pequeña colaboró
con la Nasa en el descubrimiento de dos
asteroides fue creo que en junio o Julio
Ajá fue uno de esos dos meses en donde
nos mandan un correo diciendo que sí
había sido un asteroide que estaba ya
este catalogado como posible asteroide
entonces fue ahí cuando cuando mi papá
baja las escaleras y dice Ay qué creció
qué qué pasó Y si al final sí había sido
un asteroide lo que encontraste yo
emocionada la verdad el camino que
comienza a andar Ashley tiene brechas
abiertas Por mujeres como Julieta Fierro
una reconocida astrofísica mexicana
estudiosa de la evolución química del
universo A ella le tocó luchar por la
equidad de género y considera que aún
hay pendientes en esta materia todo el
proyecto
educativo está hecho pensando en los
hombres pero no en los tiempos
biológicos de Las mujeres así es que
para que haya más mujeres en la ciencia
necesitamos becas más prolongadas que
haya guarderías que hay apoyo para las
mujeres que quieren tener niños a la par
que estudiar o dedicarse a la vida
académica A su corta edad Ashley está
consciente de los retos
deberíamos dejar atrás esa idea del
machismo y la misoginia y
hacer que cada vez más haya más igualdad
de equidad y más mujeres y niñas se
metan en la ciencia porque la verdad es
un tema que nos beneficia a todos todo
gira alrededor de la ciencia Entonces es
un tema que es muy importante apoyar la
pequeña aficionada tiene la fortuna de
contar con el apoyo de su padre no trata
de imponer nada pero si dentro de las
posibilidades conducir
esa vocación Bueno sobre todo si tiene
que ver con lo que mi propio interés
como afición la astronomía en este caso
y en la ciencia en general faltan varios
años para que niñas como Ashley cursen
una carrera pero ella con la Vereda
construida por astrónomas como Julieta
Fierro y con el respaldo de su familia
está segura de que su lugar en el mundo
está en la ciencia